Now that you know the basics of simple harmonic motion,
how to construct springs and masses or a pendulum with a certain period,
and how to describe that motion mathematically,
you could more or less design a good clock all by yourself.
Now, in a real pendulum clock we need to answer the question of
how do we convert this periodic swinging into the ticking of a clock?
What we do is we take this gear mechanism here,
and we allow this to rotate somehow.
Then we attach our pendulum to this thing, which is called an escapement.
Now, this gear mechanism would love to just unwind.
In fact, if the escapement wasn't here it would just unravel immediately.
As you can see, if the pendulum swings to the left this moves out of the way,
which allows it to move forward by 1 tick.
As it swings to the right, this one moves out of the way--tick, tock.
Basically, that's how a pendulum clock works.
Now, there are some problems. We have to deal with friction.
This isn't going to run forever on its own,
but we'll do a problem set problem about that.